well
the school district yes yes it is still
divided and in a turbulent state
how are you greetings cristian cásseres I
tell you that two weeks after having
fired the head of the school district
at least one of the members of the board of
directors says they want to rescind the
vote  to fire doctor jesús jara
yesterday the president of the board of directors
of the district of cavazos responded to
the accusations made by the
superintendent through a letter
that his lawyers sent to the district
where he accuses the board of directors of
harassment, retaliation and a work environment
hostile cavazos did not deny all the
accusations but clarified that the
superintendent was fired for
advantage, a condition that does not oblige
the board of directors to reveal the reason
for firing him so far it is not
known when this vote will be made,
however the last day of work  of the
superintendent is December 1
Reuters have not been able to escape a
cloud of controversy over the  Second time
in a week the team had problems
off the field with another of their
players this time it's about finishing
nerf who they decided to cut from the
team on Tuesday after the discovery
of a video on social media
I heard this armed and threatening to kill
someone else the 25-year-old
faces two lawsuits related to a
crash last year according to
team officials they tried to help him
but that this incident was the straw that
really broke the camel's back
meanwhile former rangers player henry rocks
is scheduled  Appearing in court on
Wednesday racks him up facing two
additional criminal charges and a misdemeanor charge
of driving under the influence and causing
an accident that claimed the
lives of 23-year-old Tina Centro and her dog
and the rapper Via Scout withdrew from the
lineup of performers scheduled to perform.
perform at the day festival in begues
after the stampede during their concert
in houston where eight people died
now on  artist faces several
lawsuits related to the incident
also the fbi has launched an
investigation and we close with a look
at the temperatures today we will see
clear skies with light winds the
temperatures will reach the high
seventies but in the mountains according to
our radar there are
light rains and snow some flakes  of snow
were reported in the mountains of the valley
but nothing in the residential areas I am
Cristian Cásseres with super
informative Spanish naval iris good day
[Music]